[Music]
trailer I've been waiting for
hi I'm Greg alright so before we watch
the dog food dog trail of the TV show I
could actually talk about because I've
seen all the shows leading up to this
where to give a quick mention that not
long ago we launched the patreon it's
been growing have a lot of family and
friends over there we've been at release
and exclusive video content only on our
patreon but having a lot of interactions
with the friends over there it's been a
total blast had a Google hangout
recently that went so well it was so
much fun
done I've been having the time of our
lives interacting with the community
over there we really mean a lot to us if
you could go there check it out become a
part of the patreon community of the
real rejects because we've been our most
interactive over there man it's like
it's been one of the most touching
things our hearts have felt you know and
quite sometime
anyway Marvel's are the photos I tweeted
out not long ago out of any crossover
any superhero movie coming out the
defenders is the thing I'm looking
forward to the most
you have interrupted a citywide
investigation you stole evidence from my
crime scene
and you got my one week trying out and
let's stop talking who the hell are you
My name is Matthew Murdock nurturing is
my favorite
how does being Harlem's here allow you
to live in a comfortable life well
people think there's a need to meet hey
[Music]
who you who you owe
how come you can't be hurt what's the
deal what does this nah I mean more like
you what you're on the same side you for
the devil tells teaching the smartass
detectives about my nipples are so hard
right ex-con of it and the kid with the
Chloe the war for New Yorkers here so
get your [ __ ] together I think it is
pretty cool
hahaha
[Music]
now you're talking about the bulletproof
blind ninja whatever it is you are
classy oh my god I can are when are we
watching this trailer over and over
again on my own okay alright alright
sorry I got my thoughts are just racing
with enthusiasm right now because all
you want to do is talk about why you
love each and every one of these
characters so much that I'll try to just
only talk about what's in the trailer
here but Matt I just if you watched all
the Marvel Netflix shows how could you
not be so if you're not excited for this
I'd be so surprised
does this looks so rewarding it's got
more than just the main defenders
characters you mean in a trailer you do
you see that they're going to definitely
bring recollect or everyone knows that 6
and the trailer misses in the trailer
Claire temple I mean I would be very
disappointed clear especially wasn't in
here I had a feeling it would be it
would somehow be Claire who helps Danny
Rand and Luke Cage help start working
together banter between Jessica Jones
and Matt Murdock looks like it's going
to be one of the best parts of it
because it from what I'm seeing here I
feel like we're going to get very
specific chemistry between Luke Cage and
iron fist Powerman and very specific
chemistry kind of like a cat-and-mouse
game between Jessica Jones and Matthew
Murdock and I gotta say as much as I was
on those people who especially didn't
love Finn Jones's portrayal of Danny
Rand in the iron fist show I'm putting
faith out there that he will do better
in this one we didn't really get a good
strong glimpse of him fighting in this
trailer I'm hoping that's like my main
thing you know like the problem with him
an iron fist like his acting is okay and
his fighting is not that good I like the
new haircut he has I mean that looks
cool Danny Grant iron fist sworn enemy
the heat he doesn't sound like that the
whole trailer that's so that's what I
like - I mean it sounded like his tone
voice changes sometimes that's Humana
where they first meet Luke Cage and iron
fits that where you know he were Luke
Aegis and owning Danny and then Danny
you know hones in on Sheehan and punches
Luke Cage in the face that was like a
cool that was a moment where I was like
cool iron fist moment if there's one
character I'm really help me makes it
appearance in the show from the other
shows is Colleen wing she was the best
character an iron fist Amin she would
make sense to help out the defenders and
I'm really hoping she makes an
appearance here the biggest difference
for me is three out of the four
defenders I truly just love them as
people as characters more than just cool
superhero powers because it's something
that shows you so well they developing
capitalized so much on these characters
personal lives outside of any superhero
moments that you just love them for the
people that they are so the scenes I'm
most excited for are like the
dialogue-driven scene so get me wrong
Matt that [ __ ] like when they're in the
hallway I'm assuming that links to a
little viral video of the elevator
sequence because I like that look Darren
above Matthew Mara documents ears and as
I think about heard the trailer right a
scarf wrapped around his eyes I like to
look as much as Jessica Chobot to make
fun of him I thought it looked pretty
cool like that and that whole shot of
them working together fighting that was
a pretty sweet shot but this seems I'm
most excited for are there character
interactions where they're just talking
with each other and one thing I really
like to see from the show is a
conclusion to the hand I mean the hands
really been built up in daredevil season
2 or all throughout Iron Fist here I
mean they're bringing back Elektra and
you get a couple of cool moments of
lecture more than just you know seeing
her laying down you pay close attention
to the trailer that cool hallway shot
the lectures is like walking up to them
like a t-1000 behind them and there's a
shot where she punches daredevil through
the glass I'm really looking forward to
seeing what they do with her character
there because it looks like she's gone
full evil in this role probably some
kind of my control maybe she thinks
she's fulfilling the destiny that the
hand please she's met for in this
trailer they're just showing the bad guy
elements of a lecturer but the defenders
are all in that hallway then they have
that shot where a lecturer punches
daredevil through the through the glass
looks like she might be a lot stronger
than when we last saw her and I'm sure
that's going to play a lot of
psychological [ __ ] with Matt Murdock
because that's one thing I think this
show is probably going to do really
well is not only seen these heroes have
to come together and get along I imagine
there's going to be a lot of
psychological turmoil that will begin
unfolding as the episodes progress I'm
going to watch this all in one day I
think I'm just going to only eight
episodes I think I'm going to carve out
a day from like 2 p.m. to 10 p.m. where
I just watch all these episodes and I'm
really excited Sigourney Weaver's in
this I don't know much about her
character a lot hasn't been revealed
about what her character is doing I like
that they're keeping that a mystery
because I mean there's when everyone's
gonna tune in I think this one trailer
alone will get so many people to tune in
but Sigourney Weaver being the main
villain adept it's a rock Brad when I
heard she was cast as the villain I was
like yeah knowing the acting chops of
Sigourney Weaver how intimidating that
woman can be I could see her being some
super powerful woman whose enemy becomes
the defenders I really loved the Nirvana
song in the trailer too I think that
work super well and as much as I love
Jessica Jones as much as I love Luke
Cage and I and I do like iron fist I
didn't love iron fist as much as any of
the other shows but I did overall like
the show I have a lot of complaints the
Daredevils my absolute favorite out of
the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe so
he's especially my favorite out of all
the Marvel character shows on Netflix
I'm hoping that the action in this show
it has to live up to the daredevil fight
scenes or be better I'm actually I
expect it to be better it's like that's
my demand you're getting all these
characters in one show together this has
to be better action in the daredevil
show because the honor of finished
action wasn't so good and the Luke Cage
and Jessica Jones action and while cool
at times you know is never as wildly
impressive as anything we've seen in
daredevil because you know jessica jones
and luke cage around martial artists but
here i'm really hoping the action is
directed super well of stick gets
involved in some of the actual fighting
stick tends to be a lot more of a lone
warrior who's very selective about who
he works with i'm really looking forward
to that scene where he's talking to all
for them that there's so much so much
for too
Oh subscriber the real rejects click
that notification Mel follow me on
Instagram Twitter yada yada yada I go
check out our patreon become a butter
the community my wife is traitor again